yo it's austin i'm brandon i'm zion i'm
edwin i'm nick
and we're pretty much all right so today
we're with buzzfeed and we're going to
be playing
who's who so let's see how well we know
each other
who's most likely to forget choreo mid
performance
austin
happens all of us though it does happen
to all of us we've all had ourselves
myself
that's his thing actually he always gets
so into what's happening that like
everyone else starts dancing and he's
still here so he's still right here
there's got to be a clip of it somewhere
who's most likely to nail choreography
the quickest
yeah i gotta give it to nick though even
though i'll get it i feel like nick is
always smoother faster
yeah yeah nick gets his smoothest
fastest yeah nick's good at like
copying like the actual choreographer
yeah like he knows how to make the move
look like the actual move
yeah yeah he's saucy saucy
i mean i hope i pick up choreography
fast i've been doing it since i was 9
years old
if i was messing up then i'd be like
damn i really fell off
who's most likely to spontaneously get a
tattoo on a night out
even though you didn't get a tattoo when
there was a tattoo at the last two
places you went to
nice it's because oh boy there's a
tattoo
there's so many people there yeah me and
zion got our group tattoos spontaneously
we didn't really plan it we were just
like yo let's get let's get the tattoo
today technically we all have one
spontaneous tattoo because we all
tattooed each other before
and we all just when we got there we
who's most likely to ghost in the group
chat
this guy i'll give like a little like
exclamation point
like yeah i guess they're right we play
video games you don't even speak on the
mic you see
i don't know what's going on like i know
everything that's like written in the
group chat like you can talk about it i
don't know what you're talking about but
like
it's like okay so i'm like why are you
answering because like i just like don't
i don't know it's a good point yeah i
feel like
this like reads it and goes okay all
right cool this doesn't respond
okay like confirm that he does that it's
true actually a quick little story
that's actually a great example because
even on instagram i'll look at a picture
and be like wow i like this but i don't
actually
who's most likely to be caught napping
oh i think it's me actually no there's
tons of videos of me
i know it's not hard
who's most likely to be caught on their
phone texting
yeah so which makes no sense
but there's no actual action involved
[Laughter]
yesterday we tried it the other night i
guess i think that the point of do not
disturb is so that it doesn't notify you
when your phone is like
closed yeah
who's most likely to be called taking a
selfie edward
yeah bro we won't do these things evelyn
i don't know man
the chronological like history of pretty
much bear has been
more than a hundred times i've kind of
you just like checking yourself in the
light like now you can take your
pictures sometimes he's
just checking himself in the lights i'm
like yeah but even even
even down to like even down to like
edward's like the best i feel like at
the tick tock thing
like he's always so i feel like for most
of him
so yeah i guess that kind of counts
chronological order of amounts of
selfies that probably take the most
[Music]
the door to do something probably
probably it's crazy like i'm up so early
but i'm not
ready for anything i'm supposed to i
feel like as
far as throwing an outfit together i
that's like between me and z we'll just
throw on whatever i'll control whatever
i do
yeah yeah who's most likely to be the
last one ready for the day
or me oh i was gonna say well yeah
it's interchangeable but it's funny
because they're the first ones out
like we're just like oh well for me i'm
up but i'm not up like you know
i'm just like he's half awake on his
phone
it takes me about two hours to actually
like get going he's like an old computer
he's booting up his stuff
yeah you gotta give it a second don't
pressure it don't
trying to have a routine like i wake up
and work out
like haven't been working on too well
but yeah usually i wake up like
like literally like seven o'clock but
then and then i won't be like out like
out and about until like yeah
he won't come out of his room who's most
likely to cook dinner for everyone else
i'll say it yeah yeah that's a good one
i wasn't the one to be like hey guys i'm
making stuff like yeah
i considered myself a good cook i grew
up a pretty picky person
so like i had certain things that they
had to be really good for me to like
them
i didn't think you were good until i
tried that
who's most likely to post mates
breakfast lunch and dinner
yeah but that credit is busting
nah but uh i just got started on hello
fresh so like now it's like one month
it's turning over one uber eats every
like
week better yeah but it's honestly
better like
postmates is like it's bad it's
difficult
dangerous like yeah yeah the amount of
times i see a dunkin donuts
postmates and i just
was like who's most likely to start the
next tick tock dance trend
brian yeah
no that's not true that's not true
you're right stop lying to yourselves
no yeah zion wouldn't start one i'd be
like you should do this
yeah yeah yeah he'll come up with the
idea okay i feel like evan would be the
one to actually execute it yeah i feel
like
me and evan would probably be like all
right we should just make more we're
like old school millennials yeah
like we're like how does tick tock work
i i love tick tock i just don't know how
to use it
for myself you know i'm saying i'm just
like
i'm just glad i have a kid now i can use
that as an excuse that i'm old and don't
understand technology anymore
we're all still mad young like don't get
a twist don't get twisted
who's most likely to be secretly lip
singing underneath their face mask
brandon i would definitely i'm always
saying
i was gonna say me i'd do that even when
i have headphones like i know people
could probably hear me around me but i'm
like
what are they saying lip syncing though
like not actually singing with it just
just nothing oh just mouthing the worst
yeah
all day all day all day yeah i'm out of
the world there's music playing i'm okay
it's funny it has nothing to do with lip
singing but whenever like i'm in my room
and i know it's brandon walker around
the house because he's like he's
always snapping he's just always happy
i'm always like just
i'm like that's random bro who's most
likely to write
the next pretty much hit him him him
me
i'm being very honest with myself right
now i'm like i know i'm not the best
writer but
i i i give great creative input in the
room that was the only thing about
writing
actually though is that every anytime
there's anybody in the room even if you
pitch ideas they don't they don't aren't
the final ones
all the ideas end up you know well yeah
energy is energy
thank you guys for tuning in and thank
you buzzfeed for having us
check out our new ep smackables out now
everywhere
show it to everyone you know and uh
don't forget to twerk to it too it's out
now
i'll plan for youtube
pretty much peace
you